you know the team say like I want to
build x amount because I want to do x
with the money like I want to pay off
this credit card whatever so how are you
going to do that what job are you
working like I Rely a lot on like ratios
as well I think that's always really
good to look at so like okay I want to
do three Deals all right well how many
CVS do you send to do a deal let's break
that down into week by week so how many
CBS you can send a week just relying on
the data knowing what works for each
person I think no one's weekly plan is
the same as well because you all have
different ratios you're all doing
slightly different things a different
like skill levels spinning all those
plates doing different things like